certains humoristes vous êtes un
comédien mais vous êtes également
compositeur auteur de chansons il a dû
vous arriver de faire travailler chez
vous avec votre piano des artistes bon
alors je voudrais que vous nous montrent
riez comment ça se passe
bon alors je fournis le piano oui les
artistes et j'ai même une partition la
balle a alors vous nous montrez comment
ça se passe comment comment on fait
répéter comme en ce moment on fait
répéter les accords de piano par
conséquent c'est ça qui va venir à moi
non effectivement alors essayé avec ou
sans thil ouzou sont ils
[Applaudissements]
à ce que c'est bon d'être une femme pour
pouvoir dire et le texte une fois d un
homme et vous dites vous après à ce que
c'est bon d'être un homme
ségou l'homme c'est ça oui mais c'est
bon d'être un homme pour pouvoir dire à
une femme moi c'est net alors voilà
votre notre vote ne s'abaissera c'est
bon d'être un homme pour pouvoir dire à
une femme c'est beau d'être une femme
pour pouvoir dire à annaba à l'auditoire
cas c'est pour des travaux pour voir du
3 4
[Musique]
des flammes c'est bon de l'auteur le
timbre est joli joli terre il voudrait
peut-être votre voix serait plus
juteuses si elle est montée un peu c'est
le b c'est plutôt ses ventes baisser un
peu le lac walker et voyez vous vous
allez vous à terra mois avait monté un
peu le sens mais moi je suis baryton
martin oui pourquoi ma paire de pompes à
martin je m'appelle dari oui mais moi
non mais moi je suis baryton martin mais
moi je m'appelle larry alors séparé du
baryton d'accord comme ça il ya 3-4
[Musique]
c'est mieux ça fait du bien c'est bien
ça prend du génie guerre ça s'apprend
dès lors de sa pente du tricot
[Musique]
on y croit c'est bon tu sais pas ce que
ça non je n'ai pas fini
donc c'est même complètement un discret
mais on me dit que ça on dit ah non là
j'ai vu là non
[Rires]
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]